Aleksander Kwasniewski: Distinguished director,
professors, dear ladies and gentlemen, dear
students, I hope some students from Poland
as well, (speaks Polish). Some students from
Poland are here, so this is an additional
honor for me. Dear friends, I'm extremely
glad to be a guest of Columbia University.
Thanks for nice and very kind introduction.
And, first of all, I'd like to thank you for
this invitation. It is a source of great satisfaction
to me to be able to meet with representatives
of the United States intellectual elite, with
the community that is sketching the path of
the future, not just for America, but also
for the entire world.
Indeed, that is the dimension of today's debate
at the World Leaders forum. I'm very pleased
that Columbia University, one of America's
most prestigious places of higher learning
is closely affiliated with Poland. It was
here that the Polish Studies program was created
two years ago. Thanks to this program, the
research is being conducted into Poland's
more distant and contemporary history and
our country has become much better known to
the American public opinion. I would like
to thank cordially the authorities of Columbia
University, especially its Eastern European
Studies Center for supporting this wonderful
undertaking. I would also like to thank the
Katsushika Foundation and the Semper Palonia
Foundation. I hope that it will be possible
for the Polish students, faculty, to launch
operations in the near future at this renowned
university which will make our country even
better known to Americans.
Ladies and gentlemen, dear students, two notions
have modeled the most recent quarter of the
century of Polish history: freedom and solidarity.
Today no one has any doubt whatsoever that
what happened in Poland 25 years ago deserves
to be called a turning point. The formation
of Solidarnosc, Solidarity, in 1980 changed
the course of history and it initiated changes
throughout Europe. The sowing of Solidarnosc
has led, although not immediately, to a great
yield. In Poland this took place in 1989 in
the form of the Round Table Agreement between
the authorities and the opposition, which
demanded democratic changes. Consequently,
the first non-communistic government was formed.
Immediately thereafter, just like a domino,
changes took place in Eastern Germany, the
Berlin Wall fell. The Velvet Revolution occurred
in Czechoslovakia. Changes took place in Hungary,
Romania, the Baltic States. And the Soviet,
finally the Soviet Union disintegrated. The
Iron Curtain which had seemed was supposed
to have split our continent asunder for eternity
simply and suddenly melted away. The Cold
War came to an end. The processes of Enlargement
NATO, and the European Union, demarcated a
new era. An era of openness, cooperation,
and integration. Poland is an excellent proof
of the immense creativities strength freedom
arbors. The greatest resource we had at the
starting point was human energy and creativity.
The Poland of 1989-90, when we embarked on
the path of transformation, and contemporary
Poland are, in fact, two different countries.
Some examples. Our gross domestic product
has grown over these 15 years by 42 percent.
This is the greatest increase among all the
Central and Eastern European states. The year
of 2004 had particular meaning as that was
the year Poland acceded to the European Union.
It was a time of truth for the competitiveness
of our economy. The results have proven to
be spectacular, especially in terms of exports,
which compared to the previous year, have
spiked by more than 37 percent. The Polish
economy has modernized.
It is not just that
it produces incomparably more than 15 year
ago, but that at the same time it also consumes
one-third less one-third less water, one-half
less coal, with admitting ten times less dust
into the atmosphere. Living conditions have
improved considerably. Poles live three years
longer on average. There are four times more
phone lines and three times more passenger
cars per 1000 inhabitants. We are experiencing
an educational boom. You, dear students from
Poland, are a good example of this educational
boom. Now in Poland we have two million students
in the universities and that is five times
more than in 1990. Nearly every other young
Poland is studying.
Although we are still not a wealthy nation,
this year's UN report ranks Poland high in
terms of living condition in number 36. We
are among the most developed nations, of course,
and that is necessary to underline. We also
have problems. We must urgently create new
jobs, reduce public debt, and effectively
reform the healthcare system. You will concur
that these Polish challenges sound very familiar,
even here in America, and especially in Western
Europe. We can see the problems which we have,
challenges which we face, they mean simply
normalcy. Including all its splendors and
shadows, but this normalcy is really fact
measure of our success.
Dear friends, ladies and gentlemen, the enlargement
of the European Union include ten new member
states, including eight from Central and Eastern
Europe, marked with the experience of communism
become a great historical event. It is response
to the avenue of the conflicts and divisions
that Europe once lived through while also
being an opening to new and numerous opportunities
for development. Poland today is actively
participating in debate on the EU's future.
This community of 25 states, which will grow
to 27 in the near future, and certainly more
after is a complicated mechanism which must
work in a coherent and effective manner. As
problems appear, people sometimes even speak
openly of crisis. However, for some who looks
at the European Union from the outside, the
sentiment of crisis may be something incomprehensible.
Or even absurd.
Europe, in the process of uniting, does not
have any reasons to have complexes or to be
despondent. Its score card of achievement
is really impressive. The countries that are
waiting to join the community also see things
this way. After all, they would not all be
knocking on the EU's door if they believe
the life of crisis awaits them there. The
reality of the EU is considerably better than
the sentiment prevailing within. The process
of EU enlargement should be continued. That
is the most certain recipe for security, stability,
and development for all Europeans. And the
best that Europe can offer to the world.
Ladies and gentlemen, one of the most important
pillars of global security and stability is
the transatlantic bonds. Poland is of the
opinion that the European Union should continue
with America to strengthen this close and
lasting partnership. Only this will make it
possible to counteract the global threats
and challenges effectively. This model reflects
much better the idea of international solidarity
than a la carte partnership, calling for cooperation
on select issues. At the same time, we are
in favor on the EU's co-accountability for
global security to be considerably greater
than to date. Europe and America may have
different views and even different interests
in one or another matter. Experience shows,
however, that whenever we want we are capable
of reaching an agreement.
A perfect example of this is the accord in
the issue of jointly persuading the Iranian
authorities to desist from uranium enrichment
program. Its achievement is a good prognostic
for further Euro-American cooperation. In
matters of fundamental importance to the world
we have common interests. I think that this
one is currently more firmly rooted on both
sides the Atlantic, than just two or three
ago. Europe and America contribute toward
politics' advantages that are complimentary,
not mutually exclusive. I think that people
in regions afflicted with crisis or countries
suffering under despotic governments would
have a hard time understanding why we cannot
combine our forces to provide them with effective
aid.
Europe needs America and America needs Europe.
The North Atlantic Treaty Organization is
also something that strongly bonds our continents.
The alliance has found its place in the new
architecture of security after the end of
the Cold War. It plays an enormous role in
integration processes, in bolstering stability
and confidence. NATO's open door policy should
be continued because it serves democratic
reforms well in countries aspiring to the
alliance.
Ladies and gentlemen, Poland feels accountable
for the direction that matters take and not
just in our vicinity, not only in the European
Union or in the transatlantic community but
also in the whole world. I am thinking now
both of problems that concern security as
well of threats ensuing from the absence of
sustainable development. The essence of today's
world is interdependency and Poland has drawn
its conclusions from this. We have not just
fixed our gaze on ourselves. We also look
to others, seeing them as partners for joint
activities or as to persons to whom a helping
hand must be extended. Indeed, this commitment
is the leverage that elevates Poland's international
position.
Our country has good relations with all its
neighbors. Polish soldiers have been taking
part in peace and stabilization missions for
more than half a century and in special way
in recent years. We know from our history
what the tragedy of war, external aggression,
the violation of a nation's freedom and human
rights, and the bitterness of isolation mean.
That is why those who are currently living
through similar misfortunes can count on the
Poles. We are in different places around the
world. In those places where there are threats
of conflict, where citizens have suffered
at the hands of authoritative regimes, as
well as in those places where are smoldering
ruins people are attempting to build a tranquil
existence anew.
Polish soldiers bring support and hope in
Afghanistan and in Iraq, in Syria and Lebanon,
in Kosovo, Macedonia, in Bosnia and Herzegovina.
Our response to global challenges takes the
form of support provided to more impoverished
nations and the participation of Polish services
and non-governmental organizations in humanitarian
operations. Ladies and gentlemen, dear friends,
in conclusion I would like to say the idea
of solidarity was not born in Poland. It is
an eternal idea that goes to the core of what
is best in our humanity. Nevertheless, the
Poles were the ones who introduced it to the
circle of political values. Who transformed
it into a social movement capable of changing
reality.
Today this is our great message addressed
to the entire world. At this time I would
like to mention Czeslaw Milosz who died one
year ago. A great poet, a winner of Nobel
Prize for Literature, a sage who spent 32
years of his long life here in the U.S. He
lectured in American universities. Milosz
was partially one of us and partially one
of you. He embodied the fulfillment of the
American dream coupled with the innocent longing
for his lost homeland. He investigated the
intricate path of the history and culture
of our times. This great humanist wrote as
follows in his moral treatise. I quote: 'You
are living here now. Hick at noon.
You have one life, one point. What you manage
to do will remain.' Dear ladies and gentlemen,
let us do our utmost to manage to do as much
good as possible for the world and for our
joint success. Let's ensure that our posterity
is as meaningful as possible. Let's build
our call to openness, cooperation among nations
and people. Let's cherish solidarity. Thank
you for your attention.